Alright Michael. Tell me the answer. let's go across.
>> Alright. Across. So. The first row it's all left, left,
but the second left doesn't matter because that's in state four. Oh
it might matter. I take it back. So left, left you
did was seven. Left and then, player two goes to medium, middle.
>> Middle.
>> That would be three, so then the pay off is three.
>> Mm hm.
>> If
the first player does left, left and the second player does right, right;
then we're going to go left, right, left again, or for a minus one.
>> Mm hm. Oh wait, hang on. Left, right,
left. Yes, huh, yeah. The next row should be
exactly the same as this one, except for in
that third case. So it should be seven, three.
And the r, the difference there. The r in four
only matters in this case where we've gone to the
right state in [INAUDIBLE], sorry, right action from state two.
And so that should give us a plus four, so four.
>> Correct so far.
>> All right half way there, so, all right now, now, we've
got something different so now player one is going to the right,
so now actually player one's choice in state four never matters, so
the next two rows are going to be identical to each other.
And so in the first case, oh, actually
[LAUGH] all of these numbers are going to be
identical to each other, so player one goes
right, player. Or, sorry, player A goes right, player
B has to go right. There's no choice.
So we're going to get 2s, no matter what now,
so it's going to be two, two, two, and then
the second row will repeat that two, two, two.
>> Okay. So there you go. Michael, you are correct. You can feel very
good about yourself. Very good, very good. So you're right, Michael, we do have
we do have this nice little matrix and we
have these numbers, and you know what's really interesting about
this? That we can figure out what the payoffs
are for B without having to do any additional work.
>> That's true. But it's even more interesting than that. Which is, now that
I've written down this matrix, nothing else
matters. This whole tree, all these rules.
>> None of it matters. It's irrelevant.
>> Wait, wait, but. Okay.
>> Because everything about the game is captured here in this matrix.
This is actually called the matrix form of the
game, and it comprises everything you need to know about
it. It doesn't matter ha, what it means to go
left or right or what it means to go middle
or whatever. The point is by following this strategy and
this strategy, you end up with seven for a. This
strategy and this strategy, you end up with two for
a, period. And how you got there does not matter.
>> But it does creep me out a little bit that
what your saying is that all that matters is the matrix.
>> You know
we should write a movie about that.
>> I think it's been done and it's scary.
>> Well, not the first one.
>> It was kind of scary. Like people are
trapped in this big box and their slurpyness.
>> But their happy.
>> But they don't know their happy.
>> What do you mean they don't know their happy?
>> [LAUGH]
>> What is means to be, Michael, Michael, Michael.
>> Speaking of which now how do we, how do
we figure out. What do we do with this now?
>> So that's the big question right?
So, what was the whole point of doing reinforcement learning? The whole point
of doing reinforcement learning was to
optimize your long term expected reward right?
>> Yeah.
>> And so you pick the policy that would get you to the best place
possible, so here's a question I have for you. Give that this is everything we
need to know, this little matrix of values. These are all the policies A could
choose from. We're calling them strategies here.
But, you know, strategies, policies. There are four
A can choose from. And there are three B can
choose from. What will you think A and B actually do?
>> Okay, so, you know? A wants the rewards to be high.
So, seven is the highest, so A should choose the upper left corner.
>> But A can't choose the upper left corner.
>> Why?
>> A can only choose a strategy. B gets to choose some strategy.
>> I see. So A is choosing the row and then B
gets to choose the column.
>> Yeah.
>> So then B should choose that also because that's what A wants.
>> No, B wants to maximize what B gets. And remember, B always gets the
opposite of A because. Because it's a two-player,
zero-sum, finite game of perfect information, deterministic something.
>> So, so you're saying that if we, if A chooses the first row.
>> Say. Mm-hm.
>> Which is the left, left strategy, and B now has
a choice between three values and will choose the one that
is worst for A, which would be the minus
1, so that would be a terrible thing to do.
>> Yep.
>> Okay then, so then what if A chooses the second row?
>> Okay if A chooses the second row?
>> So now again B is not going to let them have that seven which is kind of
sad, but still cant make it to bad for
A so B would choose the middle right. Strategy.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then get, and then that would be a 3 for A, a minus 3
for B. But wait, hang on. So that was done thinking of it as A move,
A kind of making the choice first.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That doesn't seem fair.
>> Okay, well then do it the other way.
>> Alright, so if B chooses first, then B could choose
the far right column because that's where the minus 1 is.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That's where it's going to be happiest. See,
B seems kind of, kind of mean. It's like
it's happiest when others are suffering. Well, but
A is also happiest when others are suffering.
>> I see. So, if B chooses that column
then A wants to choose the second row and get the four, so
B could choose the middle column, which then A would choose the two.
>> A would choose what?
>> One of the twos. One of the bottom two rows.
>> No he wouldn't.
>> Oh, right. A is trying to maximize, so A would choose
one of the top two rows. Oh, yeah, that makes more sense.
>> Right.
>> Then choose a three which is better for B
than having chosen the far right, and B could choose
the far left column, but then A would choose one
of the sevens, and B would be unhappy with that.
So we'd end up with B choosing the middle column
and A either choosing the top or the second row. Mhm.
>> So that's kind of the same answer we got the other way.
>> Yep.
>> Huh.
>> That's exactly right.
>> And is that, was that just luck, or
did you make this example to make that happen?
>> No, I didn't make this example to make that happen.
In fact, the process you went through is exactly the process
you would expect to go through, and you will always end up with the, with the
same answer. For a two player zero sum
game. You know, deterministic, finite, all those other words.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The process you just went through, is exactly the
process you would expect to go through. So let's see
if we can, if we can be a little bit
more, you know, explicit about the process you went through.